I'm just gonna go and you shoot me up
some hair wouldn't have sex with a
prostitute behind the dairy Mart or
something like and I don't know about
that it's a yeah I'm gonna not gonna lie
wouldn't do it but it doesn't sound like
not fun I know you released a few
Twitter videos and you weren't thrilled
with the the hopper AIDS
viii I think that the title was the AIDS
epidemic there's no exact role of aids
itself right no one trouble Dave
yourself Shh it's not no more talking
you're not a moderator you couldn't be a
moderator if you wanted to I do I don't
want that and if Jeff ever tells you to
stop speaking you have to stop speaking
not to do that so just don't spend the
happy - I'm Way too polite for that way
to play we're not on we're not on
Twitter like when I'm on Twitter gloves
are off it's yeah it's it's just yeah
it's like you want the you want the
little blue checkmark scalp I understand
there's some of there's some of them so
it's not the first time I've gone for it
either to be honest no okay so so what
was it that I mean I know you made a few
claims I kind of have some in memory but
I want you to represent your own views
and what your issues were with with the
video that I released so I'm not
misrepresenting you okay so I I would
say that the videos that I made on
Twitter were just mostly satirical and
like hyperbole for the most part but I
did I went ahead and I made kind of a
long-form a youtube video about it
addressing so the concerns that I had
and I kind of broke it down into there
were three main grievances that I had
with it one was on the term being used
whether it was an epidemic or not there
was this this statistics and then there
was the research money issue that I had
okay and like a few of it okay so the
the question of whether something is or
isn't an epidemic I mean by and large we
don't usually call something an epidemic
outside of you know media and in
hysteria unless the CDC classifies the
bats and at a particular point in time
they did actually classify aids is an
epidemic and the numbers do kind of show
that it it does seem to fall in line
with what they would usually call an
epidemic okay
did you want did you want to go can I
respond oh please Orwell means is we can
just do this casually it's fun yeah no I
just don't want I just don't want to
interrupt you especially when you're
doing it by Skype you know
I want to be really clear before we go
on down the trail about what the video
was about and it was that the AIDS
epidemic and the reporting and the
cultural hysteria was a was a hoax the
exaggeration as reporting the media what
was absolutely that an exaggeration of
hoax for example someone like Oprah
saying one in five heterosexuals will be
dead from AIDS by 1990 and I stand by
that by those numbers probably first
straight for heterosexual monogamous
couples and that's not even reflected in
the CDC so we can get those to those
numbers it was it was statistically an
on risk factor and we were made to
believe that wasn't the case we were
made to believe that everyone was at
risk when that was never the case in the
United States so that's the thesis and I
would stand by that I haven't seen
anything that would that would make me
question that oh no no I I would
absolutely agree with you that hysteria
I mean I I'm I'm 35 and I remember I
remember very distinctly the the media
hysteria going around aids right but it
was it was pretty bad at the time up
until we up until we actually developed
the the right kind of medications to
keep it in check like it was getting
pretty scary I mean do three if you
select that though I mean first first I
want a non intravenous drug using
heterosexual male in the United States
it was never getting really scary it was
never a risk factor was never a big
killer shrew true but okay think about
it like this we have according the
closest one I could find was 2014 that
there's an estimated 1.1 million people
in the United States that have HIV so
love that the what is it there we go
I have it right somewhere I just lose it
I feel so dumb that's okay
I'll go so I should give you some time
to grab that yeah you know I will say
and it's the same number I talked about
it's still statistically it's it's a
zero percent risk for a heterosexual non
drug user even if you're not monogamous
to get AIDS in the United States of
America so I would just say it's not a
top-15 not a top 20 killer
oh no especially not anymore especially
not anymore not at all at not annoying I
would say the thing is the thing is
point zero seven percent is not the same
as zero percent and it is that is an
important thing and there's also a
problem with with the the statistics of
how likely you are to catch aids but
okay so we have 1.1 million people in
the United States HIV of those I it's 24
percent of those people got it through
heterosexual contact yeah so again we'd
still let's go to you're using your more
generous number 0.7 I've seen as low as
point four I think actually maybe in
point three so there's there's a slight
variance there I wouldn't call it you
know I wouldn't call it a short term
stock market chart it's pretty pretty
stable so again I think it's actually I
think it's actually Oh point zero three
yeah it might be that low sorry I was
just trying I was trying to give you the
point seven but I always tried and give
give the I guess voice of opposition
more leeway there but again closer to
zero generally speaking if you look
closer to zero percent then one percent
so again with the premise of the video
being the the epidemic that we were made
to believe that's not the case and we're
going from one in five heterosexuals
dead by nineteen ninety two point zero
three percent to use your own words even
even at it's at its peak it wasn't close
to one percent so again I don't
understand especially when you had Pete
to so much money more funding for this
disease than any other in the history of
the United States when it was a
statistical non risk factor if you
eliminate you can count on one hand the
amount of behaviors isn't it
disingenuous to act as though it's an
epidemic and that it was this massive
silent killer when it's never been well
okay so there's a really important part
in there okay now we have to make the
distinction of are we talking about
right now or are we talking about in the
80s late 80s early 90s - okay okay so
I'd say now there I mean you could still
technically by how many numbers are you
can still classify there's an AIDS
epidemic just by how many people are
affected but I myself would not
necessarily call it that the mortality
rate for HIV infections is extremely low
but prior to the development of
antiretroviral drugs then navigating
AIDS was a death sentence it was a death
sentence and the other thing the reason
we don't know what the risk factors were
for a heterosexual male at that time
because the statistics that were looking
at the point 0 3 percent that is its
conditional first of all has to be a
single single instance of sex with a
woman who is infected with HIV she has
to be taking her current antiretroviral
drugs and she has to be asymptomatic at
the time and it's a need - what are -
what are you referring here he's
referring to the chance of a male
contracting HIV from a woman yes okay so
you're saying there's a specific study
where all of these parameters were set
that's that's where that's the CDC study
there's a there's a specific chart and
it's it's where these statistics came
from someone that's on on your website -
and the risk factor does go up
incrementally if she's not on
antiretroviral drugs and various
different other I'm sure I'm sure I
wouldn't deny that but again the risk is
still really low yes it would still be
extremely low and for people listening I
don't want to I don't have the stat in
front of me will be both every single
digit percentile I think it's probably
about that - yeah really really low so
again it would be right at the point of
the video and I think this is kind of
important because sometimes people take
things out of context and I don't mean
taking the numbers out of context I know
some people complain that I didn't give
citations I give a litany of citations
but the context is everyone knows about
AIDS everyone knows that everyone's seen
it through the lens of an epidemic
everyone's seen it as though well it's
not a gay people zyzz miss
discriminatory to say that so I was
going counter-narrative by saying no
that that's not the case and backing it
up with research so the context there is
to set the record straight because of
all the hysteria and so I think even if
we're agreeing in all this I don't
understand
what about the video would be upsetting
in that instance because again that's
that's that's the whole premise of it so
the the thing that upset me the most
about it so as we're talking about this
- there's also the other condition of
warrant
about heterosexual contact that's only
for males women are twice as likely
twice more likely and more at risk to
catch HIV from a single exposure to a
man infected with HIV right for the same
reason that well homosexual man is
exponentially more likely to contract it
than a woman if he's receiving anal sex
you know so that number goes up but
there's also I mean if we're talking
about if we're talking about statistics
when it comes down to it to a homosexual
contact man-on-man homosexual contact if
he's if he's pitching we'll put it that
way if he's pitcher and his partner has
has HIV is asymptomatic and is taking
HRVs his chance for getting for
contracting it is point zero nine
percent sure that's only three times
higher than a heterosexual man as well
if you're receiving your it much higher
you're catching whatever yeah it's it's
one point one percent even with HRVs
even with that whole thing so it's still
really low but the main part of that is
why it's so low now well is because of
those HR bees what they're incredible
it's it's always been very very here's
it would be a good example it's always
been very very low statistically zero
for a heterosexual male who is not using
intravenous drugs to get AIDS in the
United States basically your chances of
getting it are zero statistically you
can say there was a variance in the 80s
or 90s where it was way higher for gay
people but compared ibly it's still
exponentially higher for homosexuals in
the United States so it doesn't really
change the context or the premise I mean
I think I believe in one of your videos
you said you know how does a virus know
who you're having sex with asking where
you made this comparison and a lot of
people said you know that I don't care
about gays or whatever but the truth is
and we'll i'm chad with with aids on
afterwards who is gay and who does have
HIV no this is actually designed to try
and inform and help people how does a
virus know who you're having sex with
well there's there's a sliding scale and
we know of risky sexual behavior so from
my left to your right it would be oral
sex and then going to penile-vaginal sex
and then going to anal sex and then
surprisingly there are new studies where
actually men are far more likely to
contract AIDS if they're engaging in
anal sex and even heterosexual couples
they're just a
an NPR I'm just so you know that's how
the virus knows no one's saying it's you
know it's like from alien it's a Ridley
Scott film but the statistics do bear it
out so I guess I mean now we're this
polar we agree on a whole lot so I guess
I'm not seeing where we disagree we both
agree okay it was a statistical non risk
factor for heterosexuals the CDC
reflects that the stats reflect that
that's never really changed and there
was mass hysteria so where do we
disagree well there's this one there's
one other tiny little part about it too
and in this this brings it about there's
there's two main focuses on on what I
think we hugely disagree on the one last
thing about stats to people who are gay
lesbian bisexual and transgender only
account for 3.8 percent people in the
country when you're looking at the
statistics on the CDC and the risk
factor that's taking into the account
like the type of sexual behavior you're
getting into the the potentiality of the
HIV is not working at cetera et cetera
et cetera now if if over if over 96% of
the country is straight even if you know
the numbers of HIV people is is like you
know I think it's a quarter it's
something like a quarter are from a
heterosexual contact I mean that's still
then that does mean that the risk is
still there and it's still it's still
good to be informed you know wear a
rubber that sort of thing sure I suppose
one of my grievances and it wasn't the
big one it was probably the most minor
one is it felt that it was brushing off
AIDS is not necessarily something you
still have to be concerned about it's a
it's definitely not like the panic you
know this is an Oprah or Madonna coming
up there and trying to tell you you're
gonna get it sounds ridiculous yeah that
was uncanny Madonna impression by the
way I practice every day and so the by
the way I know her parents they run a
winery and I know I won't say I have a
relative who's near them and they are
the nicest people
Trump supporters not great not very
happy with their daughters also very
confused by her English accent
considering she's from I think Rockford
anyway sorry continues you're given just
rushing off aids before I distracted you
but continue with that and then I'll
respond no that's that's a that's a trip
that's a trip
yeah no that's that's pretty much like
that was probably my mind or grievance
and then the the big grievances is after
that so okay um so we would so we would
agree then because I know you said that
we didn't that I didn't provide
citations so we we would both agree
that's that's not the case then well
yeah you got the citations up I looked
at them and okay we're good citations I
think I think a lot of people and this
is a very common not that you're the
left at all but very common from the
left people who criticize they just go
you didn't give citations meaning I
didn't copy/paste the exact URL all 40
in the description what we do is we put
up the screen grab and the URL right
there so if they can't be bothered to go
through the anguish of the browser so
okay yeah we did we did provide
citations and I want to make sure people
understand because some people are
saying well there's such a variance in
the statistics and CDC depending the
year-to-year it's actually not the
variance as far as a statistical
likelihood of contracting age changes
almost zero but the number of
transmission's each year from six
thousand eight that you know that that
changes so it's irrelevant to the point
as far as brushing off AIDS listen a big
portion of what I do is comedy I mean I
had my dog playing you know Tom Hanks in
Philadelphia so let's get that in
context here too but it was hilarious
too thank you yeah well thank you I
appreciate that that's all I've ever
wanted but is something that's important
for you to note people have said that
you know you're saying what you're
saying is going to be respond for more
people getting AIDS what's ironic
there's I've caught more flak for
advocating behavior that would
completely eliminate the possibility of
contracting aids probably more than any
comedian I know I've gotten so much crap
for saying hey listen I was absent until
I was married this these are the
benefits is where I recommend it that's
hateful that's sexist of course that's
patriarchal but makes sure fire that you
don't get AIDS while I'm a libertarian
and I have been very much a libertarian
and I my view on drugs and states rights
I've also deeply discouraged personal
use of drugs so anyone who knows me and
looks at my track record I have
consistently yeah I guess sort of a
tried to encourage behavior that would
eliminate all possibility of contracting
aids and I don't think a couple of jokes
with my dog in a video changes that I
don't I don't think necessarily it's
definitely not the end of the world you
know just because there was like a tone
in a video that I didn't like or I don't
necessarily because I mean
the thing is it comes down like one of
those those things about responsibility
and you're an entertainer and you're
very good at your job I make youtube
videos we always have this this notion
of like personal responsibility that's
kind of levied on to us you know and I
get criticisms all the time you don't
know what people are gonna do after they
hear your words etc etc so I mean I
understand that I understand that very
very well I mean maybe it's maybe it's
just a difference in personal opinion
and take on it I don't know it's
interesting I would be honored with this
I actually and I said especially I
actually think that your point of view
would result certainly if people were to
file like your Twitter tender look at
the videos that you released in response
to this would actually be more
encouraging of behavior that could
result in AIDS I mean I you know my
video is pretty clear like be monogamous
be abstinent and then be monogamous the
rest of your life don't you intravenous
drugs I'm pretty clear or the thing
you've been sort of ambivalent about
drug use like I don't care what you do
personally I don't necessarily know that
you've advocated abstinence I'm not
saying that you have to but I'm saying
if we remove the tone of it I would say
that actually in that video I'm probably
doing a lot more for people to avoid
aids than my critics oh that's a that's
an interesting argument that's a very
interesting argument I don't think I
could agree with that necessarily okay
what do you disagree with on that
because I think that's I think it's kind
of prescribing a possibility of effect
more so than what either our videos are
actually gonna reach I mean is there
legitimately gonna be somebody who takes
a look at like one of my stupid crap
posting Twitter videos what not eni's
like well I'm just gonna go when you
shoot me up some heroin and have sex
with a prostitute behind the dairy Mart
or something like and I don't know about
that it's a yeah I'm not gonna lie
wouldn't do it but it doesn't sound like
not fun so I'm just saying it's a lot
easier to engage in behavior that could
lead to aid that certainly would appeal
to our carnal instincts more than the
kind of lifestyle I would advocate and
so I just do find it ironic that I've
been the target of like well you're
being you're being insensitive and this
could just you're saying people
shouldn't worry about AIDS know what I'm
saying is be monogamous don't have sex
with a bunch of random strangers
particularly don't have but sex with
another gay guy in a truck stall
unprotected
don't shoot intravenous drug use and
AIDS a non risk factor the critics are
saying aids neat and by the way there's
a huge problem that and I know people
have brought up what about AIDS in
Africa well I've talked about this a
great length I think that's a horrible
and I have made I've gone to great
lengths to separate the two and I
actually think it does a gross
disservice to children in Africa who are
born with AIDS for all of these
Americans who have contracted AIDS
entirely through behavioral choices to
be a drain on the funding that could be
going to these people that's the other
part though that's the other part so
here's the thing okay the light the last
is probably this is the biggest
complaint that I had about the video and
it just tell me I hate you because of
this but you know what no no no come on
come on No
so the big problem that I have with it
is is the part about funding and the
notion of these this massive amount of
money that's going into aids and you
were right
per person who is exposed to the virus
yeah aids gets more money than cancer
but cancer overall gets way way way more
than aids like as a big bald lump sum a
lot of that to is because there's a ton
of different types of cancer right I
mean you know you can't you can't just
be like well what works for prostate
cancer is gonna work for breast cancer
right and that's been relatively recent
to actually the the the changing with
cancer particularly breast cancer
because in you know that was a huge
there huge awareness campaigns but
before that it was all red ribbons and
aids you know 80s to 90s yeah oh yeah
yeah it's like it's like that South Park
episode it nobody cares about AIDS
anymore and that sort of yes now and I
made this point in my video too
you can you can make the argument that
with how much progress we've made with
AIDS because of that money then maybe
you can start the you can make use of
the process of de-escalating
the money and trying to find a better
way to funnel them in type of things but
research money doesn't isn't easily
transferred from one to the other before
2015 the United States government did
not pay for even half of AIDS research
since 2015
it's had to increase it and tell now it
is actually over half the money that's
going to AIDS research and that's
because again AIDS isn't that
fashionable anymore so to maintain the
current status of the project so that
yeah I'm going they have to make up the
difference now I'm making a
argument that basically that's not the
right way to do it and that's not the
right Alec ation of funds and that's
fine argument I'm totally with you on
that but it has it has to be it has to
be compelling it has to be sold to me in
that way yeah because we do have results
from all this research let me select you
this way
first off I find it funny that we say
the United States was less than half
that's the standard we have for a
country we have to account for more than
all of half by the way there are more
than two countries in the world for
people out there who don't know if you
don't fund more than half will you
greedy capitalist bastards really how
much is Germany doing not half that's
Dennis I was talking about research no
no I know I decide I just always again I
always talk about this if we just
gloated about the things where that were
the best at Americans that other
countries do when they kindly they kind
of pull one over us like oh we have
better public education the United
States if we just did like hey we landed
on the moon [ __ ] you know like it
really hey cure for polio like
everything amazing is the United States
and same thing like you need to pay for
more than half of the whole world so but
let me sell it to you this way it's kind
of the chicken or the Aged riddled egg
we got more funding by lying about AIDS
we got more funding by lying about the
risk factor of AIDS by telling people
that one in five by 1990 would be dead
from AIDS and so people said oh my gosh
we have to fund this research for AIDS
whereas the fact is again as we both
agreed it was just a statistical close
to zero percent chance of people getting
AIDS in comparison to other diseases
which are not at all beholden to
behavioral patterns like like type 1
diabetes or there are some congenital
disorders that that really destroy life
so that's my issue is the politicization
and the hysteria that was used to get
funding which was based on a lie and
it's not that I don't care about the
AIDS patient who gets that funding it's
that I really think it's unfair to not
care about the kid who didn't get the
funding because bono didn't do a
campaign so ok I'm kind of with you but
I'm also kind of not because you also
have to remember when the AIDS this area
was going around I mean we'd have to
we'd have to go back and look at what
exact year was if that Oprah was talking
about you know one in five people
it was 87 so at that point statistically
the statistics for actually catching it
was a lot higher a lot higher than what
we understand now because again that's
that's that's counting in an entire
medication that's that's turned a
mortality rate the closest we could
figure out the mortality rate if you
caught HIV back in the 80s your
mortality rate was about 86% you were
dead
right near the chance of catching HIV
was never higher that right point and we
just lied and said that it was in order
to get these drugs and there is I know
people don't like this but when you have
a disease where your statistical
likelihood is completely non risk even
if you're even if you're going out there
and you are just an absolute CAD right
you're it's a statistical non risk
factor there is a queue and we do have
to look at risk factors with diseases
and the AIDS advocates funds data and
lied about the statistical likelihood of
their disease of transmission in order
to jump the queue and unfortunately not
only do they jump the queue and get all
get all the research funding but the
American public has seen by the response
of my video still thinks that aids is a
much bigger risk factor than it is
they're not really educated on the issue
because they've been held in the dark
well it's I mean it's not necessarily
completely non a non-issue yeah but I
mean I so I looked into a lot of the
things that you said in the video
especially on like how people were
misrepresenting things the paper that
they had to retract I think was like 47%
of all the responses yes the Stephen C
Joseph in New York City but I mean even
him when he when he had cut his number
in half from 400,000 people in New York
City to 200,000 and still 2.7 percent of
a major metropolitan city like that's
spooky a spooky and it's it's freaky I
mean the the thing for me is is it
really comes down to we we have evidence
that at the time the research money
really really did work maybe it was
built upon hysteria
maybe it wasn't it's hard to say because
again you know there was a reason that
it was terrifying and it was terrifying
because of the mortality rate it was
terrifying because without
antiretroviral medication the chance was
getting it was a lot higher as soon as
we got those drugs I mean Joe Johns is
doing great
Magic Johnson to kind of peace but
as far as the cheating and he did he say
like 7,000 women I'm pretty sure one of
the women was named Todd in case people
need to take a guess I shouldn't say I
don't know but I'm just saying he was
very very he was very much a philanderer
which I'm not a huge fan of let me ask
you this what's the likelihood of
someone with type 1 diabetes living
based on modern medication that's been
created in the last several decades I
don't expect you to have that number
it's not a trick question
because I don't have it either but the
point is they need it more than everyone
in the United States would need AIDS
funding there are far more of them who
would need it and don't get it and they
don't get it because of several issues
that we've agreed on because of lying
about data because of fear-mongering and
the media and so this is this idea and I
know you agree with me on other sides
but when we're talking about anti fun
this sort of black lives matter and the
identity politics this victimhood
culture right focusing on a victim and a
held up sort of perpetuated victim
actually creates real victims and the
AIDS hysteria which we agree was false
hysteria even though the drugs did save
some lives afterward was was based on a
lie and that's my issue with it is is
the truth and I think I think we
probably I think we probably agree on
more than we disagree here did we do you
think we I think we do I mean you know
like I was explaining to a few people
who were a little angry with me because
I came out and I was like actually I
really really disagree with this on the
specific purpose and they were like well
you you must just hate crowder for his
politics like no no not at all I think
instead it's more about the tone in the
way it was handled but still I still
don't agree necessarily like I'll agree
with you that the hysteria was out of
control and I'll agree that there is an
argument to be made that now after we've
gotten such good results maybe we can
start allocating that to other areas
where people need it but it has to be
done really smartly and obviously we got
to get like the right kind of experts
into it you're right kind of people to
not mr. perfect because I mean I I do a
lot of work with medicine Sciences and
whatnot when I'm doing my videos and if
you were to ask me do you think there's
any corruption whatsoever in the
organizations that use aids research
funding of course probably sure probably
yeah it's everywhere yeah you know so
I'm I'm down with that
I think any organization whose sole
purpose is to receive grants to
their limited form of medicine or
science is obviously beholden to their
theory being proven true in order to get
those grants so it could be it could be
any disease or it could be any
scientific model I mean if someone goes
hey I need these grants to make sure
that I'm right and they go ho them wrong
the grants are gonna stop so yeah I
think you're there's corruption period
and put this by science it and research
are corruptible certainly as it relates
to research I think we'd agree on that
it depends a lot on how that's
formulated because the thing is right
research institutes not necessarily
individual labs but the labs that do
really good hard line work they have to
have all of their there's stuff
cross-examine their experiments are then
replicated and proven true or are proven
wrong those are the types of things that
you can try and trust in the people that
you have to worry about other people who
are gonna politicize science and how
they're going to represent the
scientific findings that they get
science at its core as long as it is
thoroughly and repeatedly and
historically cross-checked and
cross-checked and cross-check is
something you should be able to trust in
at least let me rephrase it
science is corruptible through human
contamination there you go there we go
all right do we feel like we've got a
good fair shake are we good can we bring
it ok good I want to make sure and and
you can go back to your folks and let
them know if we were fair but I want to
bring on Chad with AIDS as he's known
affectionately on this program and
actually he's really glad I know people
think it's would probably more of a
debate than it is but it probably won't
it's just that chad has been chomping at
the bit because and by the way he's on
twitter at chad felix g we call him chad
with aids because we are horrible human
beings but we love him um no one wants
to show up and converse with him where
he is a huge advocate for disclosure
laws where if you believe in in
disclosure can you can you guys see each
other no we had to kind of switch over
there okay good
and I'm sure Jeff you probably would I
don't know how you know let's come on
somebody hit somebody here and Zach Ford
refused to debate
Chad saying and from Think Progress
saying and I think you're a homophobic
hate mongering bigot so I would like
both you to kind of come on since this
is an issue that's put near to both of
your hearts and disgust how do we move
forward from this and help
the society at large and the AIDS
riddled community for a lot you can talk
now not kids Jared I'm from your corner
sounds but Chad do you kind of want to
do what do you want to leave it I guess
I'll let you leave this conversation and
I'll play I'll play moderator here are
sort of I don't know host I guess that's
what I'm paid for so there's a there's a
piece of this that you both missed and
that I took away from the video that
which I really liked I thought it was an
important video and that is HIV takes
about ten years to become AIDS so people
don't get AIDS like they get pneumonia
right people get a virus that decimates
their immune system and then they're
more susceptible to problems sure
something that people don't talk about
from the 80s and the 90s is the drug
culture and the sex culture of major
metropolitan gay centers people were
engaging in alcoholism and drug use and
something called poppers which is like
is what people used to use to clean out
VCRs
that has been shown to cause pneumonia
and skin lesions and that sort of thing
I was thinking about those candies that
crackle in your mouth so I'm that shows
how touch I am just going to a gay bar
just that's all you hear sorry continue
so those factors contributed to people
getting sick so fast and those factors
contributed to the continuation of
people getting the virus so there was a
there was a period of time when people
didn't really understand what was
happening and I understand that but we
very quickly realized that it was
transmitted through sex and through
drugs and in my opinion the problem is
that Oprah and the media making this
seem as though it were a massive issue
that could happen to anyone
they took away the personal
responsibility of the individuals in the
gate
immunity and we have remained the
highest infected group I think because
we've gotten to be victims in this
situation rather than realizing that we
are the ones responsible for the spread
and for our own illness today we have
fantastic medications I'm on medications
and I have great health and I have I'm
asymptomatic but if I use drugs if I
engaged in very bad sex practices I
might still be sick and even though it's
harder for me to pass the virus on the
statistics that you were talking about
the left and the LGBT community insists
that I can't pass HIV on to anybody
because of my drugs this is true Oh Jeff
you look like you're kind of kind of
confused this is true actually we've had
Zack Ford on it on the program to start
on it oh I'm sure he's been on it in a
multitude of ways yeah he's been on the
program to discuss this very
specifically and he was saying that if
you are asymptomatic you know you're you
it's it's almost impossible it's 99%
likely that you will not transmit aids
and this is true and I think it's
important for Chad to touch on because
he knows this personally he talks about
the victim culture in removing the
personal responsibility you now have
Chad can correct me if I'm wrong I think
the majority or certainly the people who
speak the loudest in the gay community
fight actively against consent laws
which Chad fights for and that means
that we have AIDS or HIV whether you're
asymptomatic or not legally you need to
disclose it and the left is very much
against that which I think goes back to
this idea that it was it was really
politically motivated as opposed to get
into the root causes of the issue I
think probably the reason why that is I
mean as far as like far left began oh
that's doing that is it's probably in a
way weird virtuous signaling because
they worry that it is being politicized
specifically to attack people who are
gay I mean that's that's what I would
have to assume they're talking about I
mean it is still if if they're on if
they're under HRVs and they're
asymptomatic and it's a single it's a
single contact I mean it is still
extremely low for gay men to transmitted
between each other
I mean it's higher than anybody else is
for
sure it's still pretty low but it's
strange that they try and advocate that
ie I'm having trouble wrapping my head
around that that's weird yeah yeah they
as a matter of fact what you think I
think will they call each end they call
you a self self-loathing homo what's the
term for someone like you who just wants
people to say just like before before
you go up to high five in the bedroom
say hey by the way I have AIDS that's it
that's all you're really asking for
right right and so it's my problem with
the media issue is that they made it
seem as though being HIV positive
happened to people like getting cancer
they took away all of the responsibility
and the ability to protect yourself from
the disease and that's what they're
doing today too because they're so
fixated on stigma they're so fixated on
things being anti-gay that they're
willing to put people's health at risk
so to me that was the big message of the
video was this is what happens when the
media politicizes a medical issue you
can't trust what's happening and when
you start funding it massively you have
no idea what you're getting yes well
pause cuz I know Jeff wants to jump in
yeah the that is the premise of the
video the main point is is like I said
it's they lied in order to create the
hysteria and to get the funding and that
does a disservice to people who are
actually up at a much higher risk factor
for for you know HIV transmission Jeff
go ahead I mean if I just want to say
blame Oprah like I'm fine with yeah I
mean okay so they're talking about
personal responsibility and that sort of
thing and kind of detract from the way I
mean you could do the same thing with
certain cancers as well I mean if you
don't want to get lung cancer don't
smoke cigarettes you don't want to you
know get stomach cancer don't be
drinking like for two liters about and
do every single day you know etc etc but
yeah you're that knocking cheered you
hear that not gay Jared sorry oh he
needs to hear this about the Mountain
Dew it's a problem just saying just
saying it it's not good don't do the do
kids don't do this okay go ahead so I'll
you continue no I'm just I it's it's a
it's very strange to me the whole thing
is very strange I I very much understand
the notion of people just kind of
disparaging you
I guess a they feel like you're you're a
gay turncoat or something like this and
the political sphere it's very weird
that's very strange I think I think lung
cancer is a fair example I don't
necessarily know that stomach cancer and
mountain dew is again I think the the
correlation between a gay butt sex
unprotected without lubricant it's
probably a little higher than someone
having a CodeRed playing Halo and then
ended up in the hospital with stomach
cancer yes so I think we'd probably
agree on some of those and yeah I do
think that period behavioral diseases
that are statistical non risk factors
for people who don't engage in those
behaviors I don't think it's fair for
them to be politicized to have a
disproportionate amount of funding
people can do whatever they want
privately but when it comes to tax
dollars in grants
I really just have a problem with the
dishonestly in the misleading chat I'll
let you go the only we have this has
gone long this has been very productive
and look no one yelled or anybody yet
Chad I'll let you go and then Jeff and
then we'll wrap this up mm-hmm I think
something that I heard from a lot of
even my followers on the right that they
didn't like about the video was the idea
that you were that they perceived you as
saying yeah gay people deserved it they
got this disease because of what they
were doing we shouldn't have we were
wasting money on poor kids with cancer
instead of doing this and I think that
whenever we're talking about these sort
of situations we have to be rational and
we'll never we're emotional about it we
end up realizing that our emotions get
in the way of actual progress and so
that's what I liked about the video was
that it was funny but it also
highlighted the insanity of emotion
based decision making so I think if you
want to comment at all on that yes Jeff
I'll let you I'll let Jeff go and then
although I mean I I can understand I can
understand where you're coming from that
to a with that and and also with
something that you said the last the
last little bit that you said when it
comes down to it whether whether there
was a hysteria or not and that it was a
lie unintentional lie or hyperbole or
a really bad campaign to try and raise
awareness and it was just done in a very
duplicitous way we can at least look
back historically and see that even if
we hemorrhaged massive amounts of money
into AIDS research we have we do have
something to show for it we got we got
the the mortality rate for something
that was knocking people dead very very
quickly and it was it was well not
quickly in the sense of like how long it
takes to turn into the syndrome and then
kills but was spreading pretty quickly
and it was pretty much a death sentence
and now as long as you're able to get
your hrbs which is a benefit of living
in this amazing country that we live in
and those HRVs were developed with the
research money that got that came from
that hysteria your mortality rate if you
catch HIV now is impossibly low it's
incredibly small so I mean it the you
can make the case on maybe maybe it was
duplicitous I mean look at Oprah you
made the case that maybe it needs to be
redressed and you know there's a whole
process where that looks complicated but
you have to at least you have to at
least marvel the fact that we did manage
to do it and and thankfully you're
you're still here with us and we'll
probably be here until until you're an
old man hopefully with a great family
because of those drugs in that research
money so uh let me kind of just touch in
a couple things hopefully wrap this up
and I appreciate both of you guys being
here
yeah listen I certainly wouldn't say we
have nothing to show for it that we
don't have drugs but I still do think
something based on a lot it's a problem
I mean I think 20 20 something thousand
people die from lightning every year in
the United States probably more than
straight people who die from AIDS
probably pretty calm provide oh no the
exact number what people say there is no
source on that I'm just using it as an
example killed by lightning now if we
decided that we were going to make the
number one most researched behavioral
pattern in America and give hundreds of
billions of dollars to teach to figure
out what causes people getting struck by
lightning and then after hundreds of
billions of dollars later we go oh don't
go out with a metal umbrella yeah we
have something to show for it but it
doesn't mean that it's proportional to
what is needed in society certainly as
it relates to the level of funding as to
compassion and I know I think Jeff has
been pretty fair here on the program and
I appreciate Chad bringing that up
listen this obviously is when people say
I want you to
I want you to be a serious pundit Hey
you're at the wrong place okay this is
the same channel has [ __ ] Bane but
it's never done in a mean-spirited way
and as jordan peterson said a lie told
very kindly is not better than a truth
told plainly sometimes we mistake
compassion with coddling or with being
dishonest with people and this was never
meant to say that gay lives don't matter
or they deserve to get AIDS it was
simply meant to hopefully enlighten
people who did not know the true history
of the AIDS epidemic in the United
States and the reality behind its risk
factor also I got to get my dog involved
with Tom Hanks in Philadelphia any time
you can fit that in there that's always
fun at Jeff hollandaise is is here thank
you so much sir and then at Chad Felix
gee thank you guys both for coming on we
really appreciate it
hey video was take another clip from the
full show Daily Show at lotta with
credit calm slash mug club where it's
available exclusively $69 a year that's
less than six dollars a month less than
two expensive cups of coffee or you can
feed an African child but just buy
coffee or join the Mudd Club Daily Show
ladder with gladder dot-com slash mug
club see you there
don't feed children